[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison de
parlement hebdo le magazine qui vous
résume l'actualité parlementaire de la
semaine avec à mes côtés thibault enoch
bonjour thibault bonjour orium est notre
invité cette semaine et boris vallot
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
députés socialistes et apparentés des
landes
absolument et dans l'actualité
parlementaire cette semaine il ya
d'abord cette élection sans surprise
mais très commentée celle de richard
ferrand à la présidence de l'assemblée
il remplace françois de rugy devenu
ministre de l'écologie c'est un marcheur
de la première heure qui devient le
quatrième personnage de l'état
mettra-t-il l'assemblée au pas c'est la
crainte de certains députés d'opposition
comme en écho la majorité serre les
rangs les parlementaires de la
république en mars se sont réunis à
tours devant eux
le premier ministre à augurer une année
de bagarres opération remobilisation
après un été difficile
en parallèle les députés socialistes ont
eux aussi tenu leur séminaire de rentrée
et puis benalla ira au sénat la
commission d' enquête de la chambre
haute a gagné son bras de fer face à
l'ancien chargé de mission de l'elysée
de mauvais gré il accepter une
convocation fixée au 19 septembre sans
attendre les auditions ont repris cette
semaine et elles ont encore réserver des
surprises enfin une oie tentaculaire
censé booster l'économie le projet de
loi pacte a débuté son parcours à
l'assemblée en commission les
privatisations et le relèvement des
seuils sociaux figurent parmi les points
les plus débattues et cette semaine a
donc été marquée par l'élection du
nouveau président de l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
élue au perchoir
mais pas dans un fauteuil à richard
ferrand succède à françois de rugy mais
des voix de la majorité lui ont fait
défaut
maïté frémont et alice rougerie monsieur
richard ferrand ayant obtenu la majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés
je le proclame président de l'assemblée
nationale et je l'invite à prendre place
au fauteuil présidentiel
la majorité absolue de justesse et
richard ferrand est élu président de
l'assemblée nationale avec 52,4 % des
suffrages
debout au perchoir il s'adresse à
l'hémicycle et reconnaît que son
élection était gagnée d'avancé en leur
disant que j'ai parfaitement conscience
que mon élection et plus le fruit de
réalité politique majoritaire que
l'issue d'une compétition de talent une
victoire applaudi dans l'hémicycle mais
déjà critiqué dans les allées du palais
bourbon
il ya une logique là encore qui est très
connu dans la vie de la vème république
où l'ancien chef de la majorité devient
le chef de l'assemblée nationale celui
qui caporalise et les députés va
désormais être à la tête de l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'il est un très proche
des manuels macro et il ya à craindre
que l'ibpt y ait un lien resserrée qui
affaiblit la capacité du parlement à
être en contre-pouvoir un proche des
manuels macron désigné candidat de la
république en marche pour le perchoir
une élection sans suspense ni surprise
qui s'est joué dès le lundi à tours sa
plus sérieuse rivale barbara pompili n'a
pas réussi à déjouer les pronostics
je regrette de ne pas avoir réussi à
convaincre mes collègues de nous
mons opportunités qu'on avait là de
lancer un très très beau message vise à
vire vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
pas de femme au perchoir le futur
président s'en est excusé avec ironie il
y avait un choix entre quatre
personnalités deux femmes deux hommes
le choix s'est porté sur moi vous me
pardonnerez non pas être une dame des
propos qui ont entraîné un flot de
critiques que le nouveau président
entend vie de faire oublier dès sa prise
de fonction il a affirmé vouloir veiller
rigoureusement au respect de
l'institution
boris vallot on l'a vu richard ferrand
n'a pas fait le plein des voix parmi ses
propres troupes
est ce que c'est le signe d'un désaveu
d'après vous voir d'un début division
sein du groupe la république en marche
je ne sais pas c'est le début d'une
division
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un scénario qui
s'annonçait sans surprise et qu' il y en
a une
la première c'était qu'il ya deux
candidats dans la majorité une modem est
une et une en marche
et puis richard ferrand fait sans voix
de moins que françois de rugy
il ya également moins de votants pour 7
pour cette élection par rapport à il ya
un an et demi
au fond je crois que ce que une partie
de la majorité signifie à richard
ferrand au nouveau président de
l'assemblée nationale c'est qu'il faut
faire vivre le débat démocratique jusque
dans ses rangs il ne le fait pas
beaucoup vivre dans les rangs dans les
trains dans la diversité de l'hémicycle
puisque on a une majorité qui a pris
l'habitude de n'écouter qu'elle même et
de ne pas beaucoup écouté y compris ses
alliés donc je crois que c'est le
message le rappel à l'ordre qui est
adressé à richard ferrand alors échappé
a quand même dit qu'il allait veiller
jalousement à l'indépendance du
parlement vous y croyez j'ai envie de
dire chiche
ce que l'on attend d'un président de
l'assemblée nationale c'est qu'il
défende son institution de ce point de
vue là cela signifierait que richard
ferrand devraient s'opposer assez
largement à la réforme institutionnelle
qu'il a jusqu'à présent soutenu parce
qu'il ya un réduction des pouvoirs du
parlement de l'or de la capacité
d'amendement du nombre des
parlementaires ses dires du lien au
territoire dans un moment
disqualification des élus qui est
considérable on a besoin que les droits
de l'opposition soient plus importants
mieux respectés on a une présidence de
commission les affaires enfin la
commission des finances qui est présidé
par un membre de l'opposition
il serait opportun que d'autres
commission soit présidée par des membres
de l'opposition
pour qu'il y ait cette vitalité
démocratique il faut aussi mieux
organiser le travail parlementaire parce
que nous travaillons bien souvent mal il
ya dans l'hémicycle et en commission des
textes importants qui sont débattues au
même moment avec des députés qui
souhaitent être impliqué dans les deux
parce qu'on travaille mal et bien la
démocratie n'est pas bien n'est pas bien
accompli voilà ce que l'on demande on a
besoin d'une expertise indépendante pour
ne pas dépendre les prévisions
économiques de bercy on a besoin de
moyens supplémentaires
je crains en réalité que parce qu'il est
de la majorité parce qu'il est un
compagnon de route du président de la
république qu'il en soit aussi le
serviteur zélé et cela je crois
s'accommode mal de l'exigence
d'indépendance de notre institution
richard ferrand n'est pas sortir
totalement de la sphère des mutuel de
bretagne qui lui a valu d'être écarté du
gouvernement et pourtant il devient
président de l'assemblée nationale est
ce que vous y voyez un manque de
considération pour le parlement écoutez
comme vous le dites la sphère est encore
en cours donc laissons la justice faire
son travail comme c'est pas à moi de
faire des procès encourent lorsqu'ils
étaient 40 dollars d'options écouter
voilà je vous ai répondu maurice jouanno
il ya une bonne nouvelle finalement dans
cette élection que c'est un socialiste
qui prend la tête de l'assemblée
nationale si seulement si seulement vous
savez c'est une coalition de gens qui
ont renoncé à leurs idées pourquoi pour
ici à marocain enfin souvent la plat de
lentilles plutôt que que des valeurs
c'est dommage mais c'est ainsi et
parfois la triste nature humaine mais
j'observe quand même que heureusement
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas dominante
un mot sur le score de marc fesneau le
candidat du modem il a récolté 86 voix
bien au delà des 46 députés centristes
comment est-ce que vous interprétez ce
score mais de la même manière que je le
disais tout à l'heure il manque sans
voix
par rapport à françois de rugy à richard
ferrand elles sont allées à monsieur
fesneau c'est en effet un rappel à
l'ordre de la majorité et de sa façon de
conduire les débats en interne
et puis moi jolie en externe papa
caporaliser les parlementaires ils sont
libres parce qu'ils sont la parole de
ceux qui les ont élus
allez on en vient notre deuxième thème
les journées parlementaires qui ont
donné donné le ton de cette rentrée
politique et c'est la république en
marche qui a ouvert le bal les
parlementaires macro nice se sont réunis
à tours en début de semaine après un été
compliqué pour l'exécutif mais aussi au
parlement avec le coup d'arrêt à la
réforme constitutionnelle le premier
ministre est venu remobiliser les
troupes
il a prédit une année de bagarre et a
appelé à se concentrer sur l'essentiel
écoutez il faut bien reconnaître que
dans la vie publique dans la vie
politique singulièrement tourbillon est
souvent roi le tourbillon de l'actualité
le tourbillon des rumeurs le tourbillon
des petites phrases des polémiques des
dépêches des réponses aux petites
phrases qui entretiennent les polémiques
et qui suscite de nouvelles dépêche
le tourbillon que vous connaissez tous
que nous connaissons tous c'est que nos
concitoyens connaissent et subissent
dans un mélange dont on peut dire qu'il
est à la fois
paradoxalement fait de fascination et
d'agacement mais il présente un
inconvénient à l'inconvénient majeur qui
est souvent de nous interdire de voir
l'essentiel
et d'expliquer l'important alors boris
vallot le premier ministre a donc appelé
ses troupes au calme et à la raison est
ce que vous direz que c'est un exécutif
à pays affaiblis qu'ils attaquent 7,7 en
2 du quinquennat
écoutez c'est un exécutif qui à bien des
égards est en échec dans les politiques
qu'il a engagées
je regarde la croissance elle ralentit
et l'insee encore donne des perspectives
de croissance cette année et dans les
deux années qui viennent qui sont en
deçà de ce que dit le gouvernement et de
ce qu'il est de ce qu'il escomptait je
regarde la politique de l'emploi le
chômage ne recule pas il faut dire que
le gouvernement en supprimant les
emplois aidés et est l'auteur d'un des
plus grand plan social que la france ait
jamais eu à connaître je regarde les
chiffres de la construction
il s'effondre et le pire est sans doute
à venir je regarde un certain nombre de
chiffres comme cela et force est de
constater que ça ne fonctionne pas et
que la promesse faite aujourd'hui n'est
pas n'est pas tenu et je crois que
beaucoup s'en aperçoive et puis il ya la
façon d'être de ce gouvernement 17
exécutif jusque au sommet de l'état il y
a non seulement je vais dire une forme
d'arrogance mais il ya une forme de de
surdité et de cécité à ce que le pays
dit de sa souffrance de ses attentes et
ce que parfois je pense y compris dans
les rangs de la majorité
il doit lui être répétée mais
difficilement visibilité c'est difficile
d'avoir raison tout seul ça peut parfois
signifie qu'on a tort mais voilà le
gouvernement serait bien inspiré de le
dire quant à gérard collomb c'est les
mots vous connaissez bien ne suffisent
pas à exonérer de la réalité de la
réalité des choses voilà donc en effet
c'est c'est compliqué pour pour pour ce
gouvernement pour les raisons que je dis
alors durant son discours devant les
parlementaires et de refiler part a
insisté sur le volet social des réformes
à venir
vous vous dites ça y est elle est là
l'inflexion sociale écoutez je crois que
tout le monde pourra en avoir
l'espérance
on a eu la présentation du plan pauvreté
je dis qu'il ya des choses intéressantes
de ce blanc pauvreté il y a des choses
qui sont connus des socialistes par
exemple parce qu'ils en ont été les
inventeurs je pense à la garantie jeunes
qui va être tendu au territoire zéro
chômeur qui sont efficaces pour chuter
lutter contre le chômage longue durée
qui vont être étendus certain nombre de
dispositifs intéressant et puis je
m'interroge menu mais est ce suffisant
on nous dit 8 milliards 8 milliards
c'est les économies qui seront réalisées
par exemple
sur les apl la même durée c'est à dire
sur le sur le quinquennat et ce sont les
mêmes personnes qui bénéficient de ces
aides sont des gens pauvres sous le
seuil de pauvreté parfois dans la grande
précarité qui en bénéficient je
m'interroge je me dis on a mis 25
milliards d'euros
sur le plan richesse 8 milliards d'euros
sur le plan pauvreté et puis on a un
gouvernement qui finalement appuyé sur
l'accélérateur et sur le frein en même
temps je crois que c'est nicolas duvoux
qui vous c'est qui est un sociologue
spécialiste de la pauvreté qui le
disaient en réalité ces mesures
particulières du plan pauvreté elles
vont être rendues inefficaces par la
politique du gouvernement dans son
ensemble parce que les inégalités
continuent de croître
je vous donne quelques quelques quelques
exemples supplémentaires les crèches
c'est indispensable trente mille places
de crèche venue de 47000 de construites
dans les cinq dernières années
trente mille places de crèche c'est 6%
des cinq cent mille enfants pauvres de 0
à 3 ans c'est à dire que ce combat qui
doit être celui de la république parce
que c'est là qu'elle est mise à
l'épreuve
elle doit se poser la question des
dynamiques des inégalités et les
inégalités sépare les deux bouts parce
que si on ne réduit pas les inégalités
la ségrégation continue la reproduction
des inégalités continuent et donc je
vous dis le compte n'y est pas alors qu'
un certain nombre d'idées que
collectivement nous pourrions poussé je
rappelle que le rsa et le rmi pardon
avec michel rocard et c'était sa méthode
a fait l'objet d'un vote unanime de
l'assemblée
on va parler de ses autres journées
parlementaires qui vous concerne c' des
socialistes ils se sont réunis à
toulouse lundi dernier au passage ils
ont entériné le changement de nom du
groupe à l'assemblée exit la nouvelle
gauche qui peinait à marquer les esprits
retour aux origines et écouter la
présidente du groupe valérie rabault
moins depuis que je suis élue présidente
en avril dernier c'est une des
propositions j'avais mis sur la table
auprès de mes collègues je pense que la
vie politique française s'organise
autour du clivage gauche droite
contrairement à ce que certains veulent
faire croire et je pense que dans ce
cadre là il faut qu'ils aient des
lisibilité et la lisibilité c'est savoir
quand quelqu'un parle ce qu'il
représente
c'est beaucoup plus clair de dire
députés socialistes et apparentés que de
dire depuis j'ai nouvelle gauche
personne ne sait ce que ça veut dire
alors boris valoir un peu plus d'un an
après la défaite de françois hollande
vous reprenez l'étiquette socialiste
c'est le temps qu'il fallait pour que ce
mot ne soit plus honteux non à dire vrai
moi j'étais
je suis député socialiste du groupe
nouvelle gauche en fait nous reprenons
notre nom oui nous sommes socialistes
mais aussi des apparentés mais ce que
nous avons constaté c'est qu'en effet
quand on parlait qu'il était inscrit en
bandeau député nouvelle gauche les gens
savaient pas très bien au nom de qui on
parle et on a besoin de clarté
on a besoin de dire aussi que nous on ne
baisse pas la tête quand on dit qu'on
est socialiste quand on dit qu'on est de
gauche et valérie rabault a raison de le
dire il y à une gauche il y à une droite
est en général utilisé au falun qu'il
formulait comme ça il est qu'ils sont ni
de gauche et droite sont en général de
droite donc nous nous sommes socialistes
et nous sommes de gauche et et nous
bleus et nous l'affirmons on le voit
dans les sondages concernant les
européennes
les européennes le parti socialiste est
plutôt mal en point s que la reconquête
passe par le parlement et par le
parlementaire
il passe par toutes les voies elle passe
par toutes les voiles à la reconquête et
la renaissance elle passe par le
parlement bien sûr et c'est important
d'avoir un groupe soudé dynamique qui
est dans une opposition franche mais qui
à chaque fois ces forces de formuler des
alternatives pour une alternance
c'est pour ça que nous avions présenté
l'année dernière un contre budget que
nous représenterons à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
un contre bruges un contre budget avec
la question de la lutte contre les
inégalités qui sera en sont en son coeur
c'est pour ça que quand il ya une loi
sur le logement du gouvernement qui
affaiblit le logement social
eh bien nous proposons un contre-projet
et c'est pour ça que dans un certain
nombre de lois nous sommes aussi à
l'offensive
alors alors mais parce que c'est long et
puis d'abord jouer où en étions-nous il
ya un an se demander si nous allions
même survivre si nous étions dans
l'opposition
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'opposition nous travaillons nous
tenons notre rang l'avons tenu dans la
sphère benalla nous l'avons obtenue sur
la question budgétaire nous formulerons
des propositions à l'assemblée nationale
comme au sénat avec détermination et
puis nous avons des collectivités
locales qui travaillent et qui montre ce
qu'est une politique de gauche c'est le
cas dans mon département dans les landes
avec la gratuité du transport scolaire
pourquoi j'évoque cette ce sujet là
parce que les inégalités
elle ne commence pas au pied du bus
voilà vous parlez de la sphère benalla
elle a fait son retour au sénat cette
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mercredi la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur l' affaire banale a donc
repris ses auditions mais ce qui a
cristallisé les tensions c'est
l'audition à venir d'alexandre benalla
la semaine prochaine passe d'armes entre
celui ci et les sénateurs coûte shield
emmanuel macron à gérard larcher
le bras de fer entre le sénat et
l'exécutif a repris de plus belle quand
un calme et les auditions se suivent
mais une zone d'ombré persistent qu'elle
était véritablement le rôle d'alexandre
benalla à l'elysée les sénateurs qui
s'interroge car sur de nombreuses images
le chargé de mission adjoint du chef du
cabinet du président de la république
semble clairement joué le rôle d'un
garde du corps avec l'audition mercredi
par la commission denquête du supérieur
direct d'alexandre benalla les sénateurs
ont tenté d'éclaircir ce point nous
avons ici le permis de port d'armes de
monsieur benalla ou jolie considérant
que monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police
est-ce que sous serment vous pouvez
monsieur le chef de cabinet confirmer
car aucun moment sous votre autorité
monsieur benalla n'a exercé aucune
mission de police aucune n'a jamais pris
la place du policier ou du gendarme et
en ce sens il n'a pas exercé de missions
de police et je puis vous dire que si
j'avais constaté cela
il se serait fait là aussi fermement
sermanni autre contradiction pourquoi la
voiture de services d'alexandre benalla
porter telles des insignes de police je
sais pas une voiture de police qui avait
monsieur benalla c est une star véhicule
de service
mais c'est une voiture avec un pare
soleil pour déploie et c'est pour ça que
le nôtre rapporteur vous pose la
question et il faut être précis
je crois qu'il fait précis de service
sur lequel il le parquet police il se
trouve que l'ensemble du parc de
véhicules de l'elysée est doté de ses
moyens lumineux et sonore pour la simple
et bonne raison que ces véhicules
peuvent être intégrés dans des cortèges
à la sortie des auditions les sénateurs
avouaient leur incompréhension
j'ai essayé ce matin surtout d'essayer
de comprendre quelle était la fonction
exacte de monsieur b n'a plus roulé
moins on le sait c'est donc sur cet
aspect qu'alexandre benalla est
particulièrement attendu mercredi pour
son audition au sénat
car seuls les gendarmes et policiers du
groupement de sécurité de la présidence
de la république sont chargés de la
protection du chef de l'état il y aurait
donc un potentiel dysfonctionnements
graves au sein de la présidence de la
république alors boris vallot cette
commission denquête a repris au sénat
alors que celle de l'assemblée nationale
a connu un dénouement précipité en
juillet est ce que ce décalage n'est pas
particulièrement préjudiciable à
l'assemblée en cette rentrée
bien sûr quand on escamote les pouvoirs
du parlement
en enterrant une commission d' enquête
qui avait pourtant été voté sans doute
un peu contrainte et forcée l unanimité
des parlementaires oui c'est un problème
et c'est un affaiblissement de notre de
notre institution
on avait la possibilité de poursuivre
les auditions dans un climat de sérénité
avec un seul souci faire émerger la
vérité sur les responsabilités comment
en sommes-nous arrivés là pour retrouver
confiance dans nos institutions
ça nous a été interdit c'est au sénat en
effet de continuer ce travail
aujourd'hui je crois avec la même
sérénité est le même et le même sérieux
l'entourage du président du sénat a
confirmé qu'un manuel macron avait
appelé gérard larcher pour lui parler de
cette commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
est
vous y voyez une atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs une ingérence de
l'exécutif sur le législatif
je vais vous dire la vérité c'est
extrêmement choquant que le président de
la république appelle le président du
sénat pour j'imagine lui dire son
mécontentement c'est en effet une
intrusion de l'exécutif dans les
prérogatives du législatif et dans la
fonction de de contrôle du parlement
il aurait dû s'abstenir voilà messadi
aussi quelque chose du rapport que
l'exécutif a au parlement ça transpire à
travers le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle
ça transpire à travers un certain nombre
de comportements des uns et des autres
je crois que il n'ya pas de démocratie
vivante sans un parlement dynamique
est ce que pour vous ça révèle aussi une
certaine fébrilité de la part d'
emmanuel macron sur cette affaire
écoutez je ne sais pas s'il est fébrile
qu'il ya peut être lieu de l'être
on en vient à boris valois notre dernier
thème la loi pacte à l'assemblée
[Musique]
pour les uns c'est un texte qui va
redonner du souffle aux entreprises et
stimuler l'investissement pour les
autres c'est une loi fourre-tout un
nouveau train de dérégulation de
l'économie
la loi pacte a en tout cas ouvert le bal
de la session extraordinaire de
l'assemblée en ce début septembre
le résumé de son examen en commission
est signée maïté frémont parmi les
dispositifs clés adopté en commission
l'article 6
il prévoit un important toilettage des
seuils d'effectifs au sein des
entreprises en leur laissant notamment
plus de temps pour s'adapter aujourd'hui
à 199 seuil en france répartis sur 49
niveau honnêtement la force de vouloir
diriger au millimètre près la vie des
entrepreneurs mais en tue la création
d'emplois dans notre pays
derrière ce texte les communistes y voit
avant tout la réponse à une vieille
obsession de certaines organisations
patronales
quant à la droite elle a plaidé pour un
relèvement des seuils intermédiaire sans
succès mais a tout de même salué un
article qui allaient dans le bon sens et
dont le coût pour les finances publiques
est évalué par bercy à 500 millions
d'euros
autre grand dossier du projet de loi
pâques la modification du cadre
juridique d'aéroports de paris
dmj et de la française des jeux pour en
permettre la privatisation objectifs du
gouvernement une cession d'actifs de 10
milliards d'euros qui devrait alimenter
le fonds pour l'innovation de rupture
d'état bientôt désengager de ses trois
grandes entreprises françaises une
grossière erreur pour l'opposition c'est
une vision court termiste d'un
gouvernement qui est là pour quelques
années et qui agit pour son propre
compte et ne pense pas au pays à son
avenir dans la durée renom saisie est
trouvée nous des solutions de vraies
économies qui permettront d'aborder ce
fonds qui j'en conviens est tout à fait
utile et nécessaire pour votre pays les
députés ont également adopté l'article
sur l'épargne-retraite qualifiée de
pierre angulaire du texte par le
rapporteur
cet article a croît notamment les
possibilités pour les épargnants de
libérer leur épargne sous la forme d'un
capital plutôt que sous la forme d'une
rente après son examen en commission
spéciale
ce projet de loi sera examiné dès le 25
septembre dans l'hémicycle alors boris
vallot l'opposition socialiste notamment
à critiquer ces privatisations mais la
gauche aussi avait privatisé en son
temps par exemple des privatisations
partielles dans les aéroports à nice ou
à lyon ou à toulouse pourquoi
aujourd'hui critiqué la privatisation
des dp je vais essayer de vous répondre
sans sans idéologie d'abord dire que les
privatisations ça fait pas une politique
industrielle que l'étain parce qu'il est
actionnaire doit avoir une stratégie une
stratégie de l'état actionnaire et donc
être partie prenante de la construction
du meccano industriel
là ce n'est pas le cas on sait pas où le
gouvernement va en fond il dit la bonne
place de l'état c'est en dehors des
entreprises pourquoi la situation des dp
est particulière c'est une
infrastructure stratégique
c'est le deuxième aéroport européen ça
va devenir avec dans quelques années
jusqu'à 120 millions de passagers par an
le premier aéroport européen c'est le
hub d'air france la compagnie nationale
qui est en difficulté
c'est une entreprise qui rapporte des
dividendes à l'état dont le cours de
l'action a augmenté de 161% ces cinq
dernières années
c'est pour ça que c'est totalement
entier économique que de vendre 7,7 ce
bijou de famille puisque c'est
l'expression un peu un peu un peu
familière c'est un non sens économique
d'autant qu'il aurait été possible de
l'affecter
le rendement de ces actions de l'état et
d' adp on fond pour cette innovation
radicale
c'est effectivement une vue à court
terme c'est prendre le risque c'est
prendre le risque également d'affaiblir
air france je donne juste un exemple
qu'est ce qui nous garantit que le futur
actionnaire des reports de paris ne
choisira pas plutôt d'investir dans les
boutiques plutôt de se développer à
l'international que de développer
l'infrastructure en france et en région
ile de france
rien ne nous le dit et puis nous avons
besoin de regarder
les lire sur la question des des des
privatisations
le temps long je crois que les
responsabilités sont partagées
il faut tirer des leçons de la vente des
autoroutes
c'est une cash machine qui aujourd'hui
échappe à l'état c'est une erreur que
d'essayer de le reproduire avec adp
très rapidement il nous reste peu de
temps brise la rue bruno le maire s'est
dit favorable à obliger les entreprises
à publier leurs écarts de salaires vous
vous en féliciter écoutez c'est un
premier pas pour ce qui nous concerne
nous pour besoin de légiférer sur cet
écart est sur les rémunérations
excessives
le gouvernement ira t-il aussi loin rien
annoncé merci beaucoup merci à marie
merci à transiter cette semaine merci
thibault mercier aurait on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour continuer à
suivre l'actualité parlementaire merci à
tous très bonne journée
[Musique]